[Musique]
gabrielle manglou artiste plasticienne a
installé sa résidence d'artistes depuis
quatre mois archives départementales de
la réunion depuis ses recherches sur le
naufrage de l'utile sur l'île de
tromelin et la découverte d'objets
fabriqués avec astuce par des esclaves
échoué
l'artiste est fortement intrigué par
cette absence d'objets usuels du passé
réunionnais près cette connaissance du
naufrage de fromage le film y sont où
les objets en fait de la réunion où sont
les vrais objets qui ne circulent pas
oui on a le la fameuse greg leca roi le
camp s'appelle ça le moulin à mailles
des trucs comme ça mais depuis que la
réunion existe
tous ces objets on al impression qu on
les conserve pas qu'on ne leur donne pas
de valeur et qu'on ne les montre pas ou
qui ne circulent pas ou qu'ils prennent
un sacré reste dans les familles mais ça
ne circulent pas et avec la
départementalisation on a fait table
rase un peu du passé en se débarrassant
des meubles et des objets pour faire un
peu entre guillemets nouveau riche est
là en étant aux archives au début je
pensais travailler autour de
l'iconographie puis je me suis retrouvé
à rencontrer les gens ici et a rencontré
des techniques et du coup avec l'atelier
de reliure j'ai fabriqué un faux livre
qui s'appelle géologie du lierse quel
titre est long petit traité d'histoire
dévorer entendu soupçonné de l'île de la
réunion et en fait j'ai plus envie que
ça soit une histoire d'imaginaire et que
chacun y met ce qu'il a envie
du coup j'ai pris goût j'en ai fait un
deuxième celui là et je compte bien en
faire d'autres en fait qui s'appelle
dans la forêt les marrons sont aussi
jaune rouge et bleu durant les quatre
mois de sa résidence gabrielle manglou à
organiser des accoudoirs ou le public
était invité à découvrir son travail
en écho à ces recherches menées aux
archives départementales de la réunion
il a installé son atelier ici avec
l'aide d'agents du service on réutilise
ans
beaucoup de d'objets qui était dans dans
les magasins dans l'est dans les bureaux
ou dans les stocks
avec l'aide un peu de tout le monde et
on a organisé donc une fois par mois une
rencontre avec le public a appelé
l'accoudoir est également eu des
rencontres avec des classes avec des
étudiants et à plusieurs reprises avec
l'ensemble du service
gabrielle manglou souhaite poursuivre
ses recherches plastiques sur
l'hypothèse de l'objet en creux pendant
encore deux ans
[Musique]